la primera vez que vi khan academy lo
que me atrajo fue la habilidad de los
alumnos para aprender conceptos a su
propio ritmo cuando ellos estuvieran
listos para ello y ese aprendizaje está
disponible tanto en el salón de clases
como en sus casas con una transición
impecable de una ubicación a la otra lo
que nos atrajo para usarla en un modelo
de enseñanza diferenciada es la interfaz
que los alumnos tienen y toda la
información compleja adicional que se
les proporciona a los maestros les
tomaría horas organizar esa misma clase
de información fue fácil empezar
afortunadamente tengo maestros que
decidieron arriesgarse vieron el
potencial de cómo ayudaría a sus alumnos
y la relación costo/beneficio es
grandiosa sé que hay otros programas de
matemáticas que pueden comprar pero
implica costo y no son efectivos la
información que khan academy proporciona
le permite a los directores de las
escuelas platicar con sus profesores
sobre el progreso de sus alumnos
reconocer rápidamente los alumnos que
están adquiriendo nuevas habilidades y
avanzando
cuáles están batallando con un concepto
en particular y los que están atorados y
que necesitan más ayuda
khan academy está ayudando directamente
porque cada día cada chico tiene la
oportunidad de tener un aprendizaje
individualizado en lo que ellos están
trabajando en su nivel específico y
obtienen respuesta instantánea es algo
que no se da en un modelo tradicional de
cátedra yo veo a todos los estudiantes
muy involucrados en lo que están
haciendo
hablan de matemáticas se entusiasman con
las matemáticas tienen retos adecuados a
su nivel y los chicos que son brillantes
en matemáticas pueden presionar sé aún
más para lograr los objetivos que
quieren el que los padres se involucren
también es muy importante porque pueden
ver cómo se enseña las instrucciones tal
cual las escucha el chico en la clase
porque ellos también pueden ver los
vídeos les da la oportunidad de tener
conversaciones con sus hijos en casa
sobre matemáticas sobre el aprendizaje y
sobre lo que están haciendo en la
escuela me emociona que los chicos estén
felices y emocionados por estar
aprendiendo
sobre todo matemáticas porque parece que
mientras más avanzadas tienes que
decidir si eres bueno en matemáticas o
si no te gustan los chicos pueden tener
éxito en su nivel para ir construyendo
la lógica matemática y eso es
sorprendente cuando los maestros y los
alumnos disfrutan el proceso de
enseñanza-aprendizaje en el salón de
clases tienes posibilidades ilimitadas